hi so i just got done shooting my music
video for christmas um
yeah it's not done yet of course
obviously if you're watching this this
is not my christmas video but what i did
want to do is if you guys were
interested in being in the video i
probably won't be able to use every clip
because i have a feeling that you guys
are going to go a little crazy and
submit a ton of them but if you do want
to have a chance of being in the video i
think it can be really really fun um
what i'm looking for is people dancing
around in christmas hats or fun little
christmas outfits um snow wear it's like
chilly out
bonus points for going out in the actual
snow and dancing around that'd be
awesome but another thing most
importantly what i'm really really
really really really really really
looking for
is
you guys opening up fake presents so you
have like a present wrapped you can put
whatever you want in it unwrap it and
whatever's inside you're very upset
because that's not what you wanted for
christmas
what you wanted for christmas was well
what my youtube video is about um it's
it's kind of funny and if you guys make
a video whatever i'll try to use it um
so yeah if you want to make those few
things i think that'd be awesome um make
sure
that when you add the video response
title the video ijustine christmas
collab clip
or clips whatever you prefer either or
is good because i'm going to be
searching for those and i want to make
sure that i get all of the responses
um
yeah so thank you so much in advance and
yeah get those in very very soon cause
i'm gonna start editing this video
together okay that's it i hope you guys
are doing well and
well that's just about it for this video
okay
bye